- [Paulette] If you hate
somebody so bad in your heart
before you pass on,
that hate will go to you.
It will never go to the
person that you hate
and all the things that you-
Bombarded the person, people with,
are the things that you're
going to go through.
That's how I feel, that-
Is the difference between love and hate.
- [Interviewer] All right, Paulette.
- [Paulette] Yes.
- [Interviewer] Paulette,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Paulette] Modesto, California up north.
- [Interviewer] Modesto.
And tell me about your childhood.
Did you had both of your
parents when you were young?
- I had my mother and my father.
He passed away when I was
four and a half years old.
My mom didn't pass away
until she was in her 70s
of Alzheimer's.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- At times, it was really good.
And at times, it was super difficult,
because we weren't looked after real well.
- [Interviewer] By your mom?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What was Mom doing?
- She was chasing an alcoholic boyfriend.
So when somebody needed help
in the family.
She wasn't available
but I understand she grew
up knowing what she knew,
how to be.
And
same as I grew up, I grew
up not knowing anything,
but I had to teach myself a lot of things.
- [Interviewer] How would
you describe your childhood?
- It's super difficult.
I was perfect student.
I loved school because home life was
very difficult.
Some of the children
were getting in troubles,
going to
get locked up at different places.
So I just blended in,
where I was seen and not heard
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- Pardon me?
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- I excelled in everything.
I was...
the person that taught all the kids.
A lot of their knowledge
from the books.
I was straight A student
and...
I didn't have very many boyfriends.
- [Interviewer] You're lonely?
- Yeah, and I have to-
Oh, gosh.
I talked to-
Oh, wow.
I have to say that's pretty,
pretty fair to say.
I-
I wrote a poem
in the sixth grade.
I think it was.
And it was pertaining
to the word, lonely.
My lonely, empty heart.
- [Interviewer] You went
on your own at what age?
After high school?
- Yes.
(cheerful music)
18 years old.
I became responsible
to pay my mother's rent
where she lived on the house.
She'd find the house and...
I paid the rent
so she could have that house
until she was ready to sell it
'cause she had bought a motor home,
a mobile home with her fiance.
- [Interviewer] Do you have children?
- Yes, I have two sons.
The oldest one is Frank Jr.
He is...
40 years old.
My youngest son
is Paul.
And he's 30-
He's sometimes 37 and 38.
He's about two to three
years younger than Frank.
- [Interviewer] And you raised them?
- Oh, yes.
I loved raising my children.
They meant everything.
I mean everything to me.
- [Interviewer] Was that
the best time of your life?
- Yes.
Yes.
I chose like, if I were to be younger,
my favorite year would be 25 years old.
That's when I had both my children
and I did everything that I could.
I doted on them.
I took them places.
I drove them crazy at Christmas.
I would take them to, it was
called Christmas Tree Lane.
And I would take them like,
if they would go every single night,
twice a night,
I just love Christmas.
There's something that's so...
happy for me.
I don't know what it is.
It's definitely for children.
I don't have to have presence for them.
Just decorations, you know?
And that makes me...
(hand pounds on seat)
excited.
- [Interviewer] It
brings back good memories
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] of your childhood.
- Yes.
Yeah.
My favorite (laughs)
is when my dad took me, Christmas playing,
let's say, one year. (laughs)
I got everything I ever wanted then.
And
(vehicle rumbling)
It was incredible to me.
I enjoyed it.
- [Interviewer] But your dad passed away.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] When?
- I was four and a half years old.
- [Interviewer] Four and a half.
But do you remember your father?
- Yes.
Yes.
He was a very good-looking man.
If I had a picture of him,
one picture and he was a cook.
He looks like Desi Arnaz
to me.
So classy and...
handsome and...
steady, real steady person.
- [Interviewer] So today,
you're living on skid row.
- Yes, I am.
- [Interviewer] How did that happen?
- I left my fiance
of 13 years.
That's the same amount of years
I was married to my husband.
I left him, not because I didn't love him.
It was because...
he became very rageful to the point,
I felt
and I told him that he was killing my soul
and I just couldn't take
the pressure that...
I felt.
I loved my job.
I was great at what I did,
but when I came home,
everything was messy.
So...
it wasn't until I started working then.
I really...
could tell the difference between Paulette
and...
that man's...
candy grill or whatever
you want to call it.
I was a lot younger than him.
I let him do anything he
wanted, anytime he wanted,
I never questioned anything.
I never...
became suspicious.
With my husband, I was pretty bad about...
not trusting.
And so I let this man
just be so trustworthy.
It was...
very comfortable for me
because I didn't have
to extra guess anything
and put extra things in my head.
So when he was gone, I would just be me.
- [Interviewer] So there were trust issues
in both of those relationships?
- With my husband, yes.
I trusted the second man
to the degree that...
I knew not to trust
him when he was rageful
and he became rageful daily.
And I couldn't figure
out if it was his job.
If it was something about him personally
or he never wanted to get married.
And that was okay with me.
I'm an open person.
If that's...
the person I love.
So,
I gave up asking the questions
and I felt like he had
this tremendous guilt
that he couldn't share with me.
It was like,
almost-
It was pretty f'ed up.
The look on his face.
So I knew that he had something,
had to have something,
but I didn't spend a lot of
time trying to figure it out.
- [Interviewer] That's
good, do you got out?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's
good that you got out.
- Yeah.
Because he did get me in the garage, once.
I had a neck surgery,
got a plate in my neck
and he got me up in the garage
and picked me up by my neck.
And the neighbor man came driving by
and immediately came over
and he dropped me like quick.
- [Interviewer] And you
ended up homeless, how?
- [Paulette] When I left that man,
I had really good credit
and I don't know why.
I didn't think to...
use my money.
To get my own place or my own independence
or anything like that.
As it turns out,
I feel that it was the best
thing that ever happened.
My choice,
number one, I didn't put my
children through terrific hell.
They did not know my whereabouts.
My youngest son found me probably a yea-
Not about 8 months ago through
a Christian people group.
And he asked that they
search for me and they did.
And they found me in six months.
So I didn't want my children
to have to hear all these stories
and secondhand things
that was going on with me.
So I felt it best that I just...
cut it off.
And I found out my youngest
son had been looking for me,
no matter what, no matter what.
For quite a few years.
And...
because I am the mother
that raised him.
I believe that he also felt
that this mother that
was out here on skid row
could still be quite sufficient.
He's told me,
I don't know how many times
that he's proud of me.
He's told me some cute
little stories about...
some things I shared with
him about him and myself
and possibly his older brother,
spiritual thing.
And the way he told me these
stories were just like,
I hear them here, (chuckles)
today.
And I know that-
That he's here in spirit, of course.
Mind, soul, body, and
spirit, I don't know.
(exhales)
Being proud.
I've changed a lot.
I'm very-
I say anything I want
just about to anybody.
I pray a lot on that.
Certain things that people
say and have done against me.
I have s-
With my spirit getting very stern
about my feelings of...
the process that they must go through.
Like, here's for instance,
if you hate somebody so bad in your heart,
before you pass on,
that hate will go to you.
It will never go to the
person that you hate
and all the things that you-
Bombarded the person, people with,
are the things that you're
going to go through.
That's how I feel that-
Is the difference between love and hate.
- [Interviewer] Are drugs
a part of your life?
- Yes, I did do crack cocaine,
in the beginning.
- [Interviewer] In the beginning of?
- Of my usage, I used for about,
14 years.
And...
I don't feel that I used
as many people out there
that are on drugs.
In the beginning, I did,
I went way overboard,
but I learned how to function
and how to...
think
and still say prayers
because no matter what.
The God of my understanding tells me,
I take you as you are.
I will change the things
that I need to change in you.
Not them, their-
- [Interviewer] This
began, the drug use began,
during your second relationship?
- After.
In...
2005.
- [Interviewer] So when
you became homeless?
- I started working in the streets.
I mean, everything.
I was a suburbian.
Learning how to grow up in s-
gangster life.
'Cause these are gangsters out here.
They're hell-raisers.
They're...
brutal.
- [Interviewer] Did you have
bad things happen to you here?
- Oh, yes.
A lot of things.
And finally, today, I just
look at them and I say,
"If you're going to like
a homie hostage, kill me,
or whatever you think you want to do.
Go ahead,
'cause you're going to
hell no matter what,
you will go to hell.
I don't pay the price and I'm
going to walk away from you."
And I end up walking away.
It's the darndest thing because...
I had some guy stick me in
a car and hold me hostage.
And nobody could get in
this car, even though,
it was unlocked,
it was unlocked and...
it is because of the power
of prayer that I acknowledge
that puts people at bay.
They can-
I don't care what they think.
I hear women tell me,
"They're going to whip
my ass and take my shit."
And go ahead,
if they think they can,
'cause my spiritual
persona
tells me, they can't get
that far from me anymore.
They can't swing at me.
They can't.
They could do other weird stuff, maybe,
that I don't know how to...
Change.
But I've learned by...
biting my way through.
I actually am my own soldier basically,
to...
fight.
For what I represent.
- [Interviewer] Have you been
raped or anything like that?
- Yep.
- [Interviewer] Pretty much every woman
that's down here has encountered that.
And where do you sleep?
- I sleep
in a tent.
I am changing where I live today
because there's been some...
strong things that have
taken place between me
and it was supposed to be one person,
but it turned out to be
the entire neighborhood.
So I'm not going to be
participating in negativity.
It's just not my style.
- [Interviewer] (laughs) It's over here.
- It's not my style.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, well, good luck.
I was waiting that here.
- I do.
I just stay away.
And...
I say to the person,
what I think is going on
and (laughs) I don't care.
My spirit is so strong.
I am
so precise.
It's incredible, it's totally-
- [Interviewer] You're investing yourself
'cause you're in the heart of-
- I've had to grow up here
and learn the true life
as uncomfortable as it
may make others feel.
I care about myself
and I love myself today
because of anything and everything
that took place in my past.
It's made me
who I am.
And I love that.
A lot of people don't like that.
- [Interviewer] Are you happy, today?
- Yes.
On the most part, I've
had to really say, "Yes."
It's been a hard fight,
but it's also been,
I've had to question a lot of things.
And when I talked to my
son on the phone, I knew.
I knew.
A lot of things were
going to get worked out.
- [Interviewer] Have your sons come to,
try to take you out of here?
- He asked me if I-
if I wanna (laughs)
He asked me if I wanted to
go to a program and recover,
and I said, "No, I'm not ready."
And now, today, I can tell you,
I know what he was talking about.
I've had to...
Reprogram
a lot of
structure around me
so that I could break through
and...
so I can be me.
- [Interviewer] Are you
still using drugs today?
- Barely.
Yes, I use...
meth.
I quit...
crack because this man,
a friend of mine started using it
and it wasn't correct,
the way I knew crack was supposed to be.
And like I couldn't get the
inhalation and the smoke.
It was like sucking, like (inhaling)
without getting anything,
not even barely any air.
And I quit instantly.
It was the best thing, actually
that happened, I think.
I kinda missed the feelings
that I used to get.
I used to actually,
I could hear angels constantly.
And I know I wasn't hallucinating
because when I would stop,
unlike when I went to jail and stuff,
I could still hear them.
- [Interviewer] This was on crack.
- Yeah.
And then off of crack,
I could still hear them.
And...
it's not that they're seeing or anything.
It's like one voice talks to me,
but several at the same time.
- [Interviewer] How do
you support yourself now?
- I'm on GR food stamps.
And I barely ever spend
my food stamps on drugs.
I mean, barely.
Probably did 10 bucks all of six months.
And I have worked the streets.
I have calmed down on that
because...
I don't care for the street owners
of each street.
They bombard me.
They try to get one over on
me and they try to use me.
And I don't play that game.
I stay away from that territory.
It's just, you know, used to be mine.
I used to have (swoosh), like that
because of the power of prayer.
But now,
I get dates every now and then,
just men driving in vehicles,
wherever I'm walking,
it doesn't (chuckles)
make a difference.
You know, it doesn't have to be every day.
And I use the money for things
that I want or need.
It's usually cigarettes or food
or
clothing
this time I want a radio.
- [Interviewer] Crystal
meth, you'll pay for how?
- Sometimes, the men that I know have it,
want to have a favor,
so they share with me,
some do, some don't.
Sometimes, there's just guys that I meet
and I'm very specific with them
that I'm not there to give pleasure.
I just want to get high and
that they don't want that.
And then, I turn them down.
Not a lot of guys,
I trust really.
They tend to get sneaky on you, you know.
Not all, but a lot of them.
- [Interviewer] And Paulette,
what's the most important
lesson you've learned?
- To trust in myself,
trust in
the path that I am supposed to be in.
Trust in my thought process
and...
(sniffs)
don't trust in the hellions. (chuckles)
That's just people that...
they think that they're
getting up on over on me
and I haven't pegged pretty much,
before they can even start their engines.
I sometimes get scared
'cause sometimes I think I'm,
you know,
on the wrong path, but I
know I'm on the right path.
I feel it.
I feel it super strong.
Off and on, it's days that I
feel so sad and distraught.
And then, there's days that I feel like,
"We are moving."
"We are chewing this thing."
Yeah.
It's wonderful.
- [Interviewer] All right, Paulette.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] And I wish you
the best of luck out there.
- Oh, it's gonna be- (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] Be careful.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's dangerous
for a woman out there, right?
- [Paulette] Huh?
- [Interviewer] It's dangerous
for a woman out there.
- [Paulette] Oh, I know.
(sniffs and laughs)
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- [Paulette] Thank you.